are you drinking and eating these pillow
no no no okay I was never a big drinker
at all believe it or not he never drank
back never drank like I always liked
some coke yeah like I just want some
coke [ __ ] the drinks oh my I don't want
to drink that's how I was so I was
totally out of my [ __ ] mind
oh yeah so so like I mean like seeing
people now I'm like okay I get why you
drink and then do it but I was just
full-blown okay doing coke and and then
it got to the point to where I was
dropping something off for somebody and
they were shooting up shooting at coke
shooting up Coco they said you want to
try it I go now and then like a couple
more times I go over there like
different times and uh one day I was
like yeah [ __ ] it whatever so tried that
I I hated shooting up pills I love
shooting up coke port pills and shoot
coke I don't know because I'm have no
idea you don't remember you can't
remember like what like our a reason for
it no I just felt like I felt like when
you shot up pills it was it you just
went through too many and then I'm like
I don't want to be dope sick right so I
don't want to go through all my pills
that quick okay with the coke I mean if
you snort is whatever you do with it
you're gonna want it you're gonna for
everyone no matter what yeah but like
that that was like a deal yeah yeah so I
got to the point to where I was just I
was just banging coke-snorting pills
kind of all day I mean if I had it yeah
well then you're just that's just your
whole life's kind of just revolves
around what what are you gonna do next
to get money
who you gonna scam yeah are you gonna do
kind of around did you have like a job
job or anything anything like at the
time that was like holding you down like
any kind of stuff in your life or no it
mean if there was I I never had like a
serious job so I never really took
anything serious back then hmm
if I didn't like it I'd just be gonna be
like [ __ ] you and leave yeah because
yeah
which is kind of like I'm working the
same job kind of jobs now but yeah yeah
I got you stick with it because you have
to walk me through the timeline how that
part of your life led up to the part
where you got a ruble yeah I mean when
you're when you're hitting it that hard
for so long it's a matter of time
because yeah you're you're either riding
around all day with [ __ ] you're you're
you're always doing something shady
illegal kind of deal like that the
people you hang out with
you're [ __ ] hanging out with total
[ __ ] scumbags that yeah do not give a
[ __ ] about you yeah they just they're
hanging out because you might be able to
get something and vice versa you know I
mean I would hang out with people I
would never [ __ ] hang out with right
so it's just kind of like that and then
you're just getting this wrong crowd and
then just this [ __ ] you know I mean just
builds up and you know everybody keeps
going the next level to where it's just
like something [ __ ] Bad's gonna
[ __ ] happen yeah so then um I guess I
guess basically like the first time I
really got in trouble Luke were you were
you talking them at all in this what do
you remember do you remember this time
yeah we didn't really ever have a great
relationship I think between the ages of
from whenever I can remember up until we
we really connected in prison yeah like
through heavy metal and just kind of it
took me like three years for being sober
in prison yeah - kinda
if I would have gotten out before the
three like three years I would have got
out and done the same thing you think
but oh I know yeah because I would some
days I'd be like oh man this is so
stupid then that's like I kind of just I
forgot I already know I just get like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah skip the whole part
about how like you got arrested you went
to County for about eight months
oh yeah no that's what I mean I was
getting at all that but yeah I come back
on take a little DJ yeah I mean so I
mean basically I we I was with this dude
yeah I just seemed like at this point
you're just looking at tornado of just
yeah I mean you're just kind of you're
in it you're in it you're just on
autopilot yeah
is trying to get drugs like not really
you don't care about nobody but yourself
right just trying to get high yeah
that's from my perspective too it's like
you know it's like you show up to all
these like family functions you know if
you do show up at all like you show up
and then you're like nodding out and
like you're dope sick or like you don't
want to be there and like you start
fighting with everybody and then it just
like everybody just like wants you to be
well but like you're so caught up in
your addiction that you don't recognize
the help that's around you and like all
the love that's surrounding you because
you're just looking for that next fix
yeah well that too but then it's like
you know you're [ __ ] up you're not
trying to hear [ __ ] [ __ ] about it
yeah like you know you're [ __ ] up do
you really know like how much do you
hate no it's really [ __ ] up because
like my booking photo looks like it was
[ __ ] horrible well you don't think
you looked that bad okay until you don't
picture you see the pictures are like
like now down the road I'll look back on
a lot of pictures and [ __ ] and I'm like
what the [ __ ] was I even like you're not
thinking like a psycho with eyeballs
you do not oh no you do not like I was
190 pounds when I got arrested and I
looked I look [ __ ] ridiculous like
under 200 pounds yeah yeah so you don't
you think you look you think you look
normal like like you're not on drugs do
you think you look [ __ ] normal right
you always think you're getting away
with it people don't know like now my
god like just how much [ __ ] I did like
seeing Pete like I mean that's why I
like a lot of times I would just be like
in my in my place like by myself yeah
like I don't have to see nobody I'm to
talk to anybody
yeah it's like you can't talk [ __ ]
talk to anybody are you so [ __ ] coked
out of your mind that you can't even
look anybody in the eye you're [ __ ]
looking at the crap you're like going to
the store to get cigarettes and you're
just like [ __ ] hope nobody's in line and
then you're just like if somebody's in
line you're just like looking at the
floor yeah you don't want to just so
nobody like looks you in the face slices
people no yeah I don't know yeah but I
honestly did not think I looked as bad
as I did or really you don't
yeah it's R it's really weird how that
how that kind of
happens so were there any actual family
functions like this we're like in this I
would always I would never go you would
never go there Oh Luke says there were
probably a couple but okay for the most
part I would always not go yeah like
family vacations my mom you're like yeah
yeah oh I'm gonna our we're going to
Mexico
yeah are you gonna go yeah I'll go Jake
are you really gonna go yeah I'll go buy
me the Bible a ticket we were like in
high school yeah so then the day would
come like 5:00 in the morning they're
banging on my door I'm like [ __ ] you I'm
not coming out pretty much at that time
yeah and there was like and then I had
to leave I think I didn't I didn't have
no place to stay for like a week so I
was pretty much just like trying to
scrounge up enough money to get a shitty
hotel room but there's a couple days
where I would just be walking around all
night and then like sleeping on side of
somebody's house I knew but I wouldn't
tell him kind of I was there like that
yeah like during the day I would do it
yeah I was [ __ ] there was one like
Easter trip to I remember where like we
all went to Cocoa Beach like you you two
like I ended up at like the Doubletree
north of the Air Force mom would always
take me and Greg like a Holiday Inn and
Jake was supposed to come and you know
came late you guys came for it one night
you showed up at 3 a.m. across Florida
that old Oldsmobile that you had just
probably [ __ ] getting booted the
whole way I was so [ __ ] geeked out
that we decided we ended up believing
like I think we left at like 10 o'clock
at night
who's we mean a couple of my buddies
yeah yeah I think I think they all burn
in prison right yeah one of them we
borrowed the tricycle for that Jimmy
Hart commercial where he was dressed up
like jigsaw really yeah Wow
and he tried to pawn my phone is that
the greasiness yeah okay but um Wow
but yeah cuz we left at 10 and don't
take that long to get over there but I
was so like I would could not [ __ ]
see I was like I was driving well it's a
good two and a half three hours yeah oh
yeah it was like 10 o'clock and
but then we got there at 3:00 and we
were driving the whole time I kept
[ __ ] missing the same exit was on the
highway and I had to keep going I
remember just doing like we probably did
like three or four loops like super long
loops on the highway no idea where I'm
going like super blurry vision to where
like you try to look at your phone
you're like okay I'll look at that
tomorrow these phones that are focused
like this playing snake was dry yeah
that's bad I mean yeah I forgot totally
forgot about that
yeah somebody had a water puddle full of
vodka and then mom woke up in the
morning God we were still in high school
right I was like 17 we weren't in high
school at the same time where we no no I
I graduated yeah yeah yeah so then um my
mom gets up in the morning and happens
to grab this water bottle full of vodka
and she I don't know how people do this
so I mean she chugs it and then like
after three gulps realizes it's vodka
she finishes it that's why I'm called
[ __ ] oh yeah I mean you know that
when you open the [ __ ] water bottle
yeah especially Luke Luke has a nose
just like my mom so if you're grabbing
like a random water bottle that isn't
yours you're totally at fault for
anything that's in it if you just go for
it oh yeah Oh every time I open a water
bottle I don't hear that Claire come
like so she drinks the whole thing yeah
I actually kind of blaming the whole
story about that about on my mom
[Laughter]